على مدار ال14 شهرا الماضيه لعبت المسيرات
دورا كبيرا في المواجهات الميدانيه بين
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه وشهدت صعيدا
هائلا في استغلالها حيث حققت طائرات
بيرقدار تركيا الصنع نتائج نوعيه في
التصدي للدبابات الروسيه واحبط التقدمها
على اكثر من محور كما ادت الى انسحابها
ولا سيما في الجبهه الشماليه الشرقيه وفي
خرسون لكن هدوء الجبهات واقتصارها على
المواجهات في بخموت بالاضافه الى استهداف
البنى التحتيه العسكريه
والاقتصاديه في الداخل قد اعطى للمسيرات
الدوره الاكبر في تشكيل ذراع العسكريه
الافعى والاقل تكلفه للحفاظ على استدامه
الحرب فلعقود من الزمن كانت الطائرات
المسيره جزءا من المخزون العسكري لمختلف
الدول حيث تطورت خلال السنوات الاخيره من
اداء مهام التجسس الى المهام الهجوميه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات